huge teddy bridgewater fan always have
been i thought he performed very well
last year in his first season as a
starter since
2015 the panthers however looking
desperately for an upgrade which means
teddy is going to be out
reportedly the 49ers have called about
teddy bridgewater
which was intriguing to say the least
because i'm not
sure who's higher on the list between
bridgewater and garoppolo but you know
what even though bridgewater's also had
the catastrophic knee injury
bridgewater more reliable to and and i
could see bridgewater
in that joystick offense of kyle
shanahan where you just do exactly what
the coach wants you to do you run it the
way he wants you to run it everything's
going to be fine
i could see bridgewater running that
offense chris yeah he certainly can
i mean we know he's a student of the
game he's gonna do those type of things
but uh i i don't think he's as good as
jimmy garoppolo i i mean
this one is is eye-popping to me listen
i i look at it from this aspect
you know i think a guy like jimmy
garoppolo can look at
all the other rumors and things that
have been out there about replacing him
right
oh tom brady okay i mean i understand
it's tom brady
okay yeah he's the goat whatever right
you know oh matt stafford okay well yeah
i mean matt stafford holy cow that's one
of the greatest throwers in the history
of football desean watson all right yeah
he's definitely one of the five best
quarterbacks in football
this is the one if i'm jimmy garoppolo
like i'm pissed off there's this one
right here where i go
what teddy bridgewater you're gonna
replace me for teddy bridgewater
that's the one where i think you could
actually actually anger him where he's
gonna go are you kidding me
you know teddy bridgewater yes very good
like
i he to me he's not really a starting
quarterback in the nfl
he's a borderline starter slash
backup yeah the stats were pretty good
last year
great it's all stats they don't want
them this year do they
you know they don't it's again it goes
into hey the stats are great
but there's so many plays and yards that
were left on the field last year
they got arguably the the best receiving
core in football last year as far as
explosiveness
dj moore robbie anderson curtis samuel
so i'm sure carolina got done with the
year and was like
what we left people open for touchdowns
and plays
all over the place and that's why
they're trying to move on so
i'm interested to see how you know that
reaction
and how this all gets portrayed for
jimmy g grassy knoll
theory for me okay looking at teddy
bridgewater's contract salary this year
of 17 million
compensation package for jimmy garoppolo
25 million maybe this is just a step
toward eventually going to jimmy and
saying hey
we can't pay you 25 this year we can't
do it
that's why we called about teddy he's
coming in at 17. maybe
and jimmy hey have have your agent don
yee call around see if there's somebody
out there that would pay you 25 million
if we'd cut you because there isn't i
think that's part of it if you keep
jimmy garoppolo you cannot pay him 25
million
this year he hasn't earned it because he
can't stay interesting
and they want to keep trent williams a
left tackle
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports